well get your children vaccinated that
was a message from local and state
health officials during
today's covet update children 12 and 15
years old
12 and through 15 years old i should say
were approved to get pfizer's covet 19
vaccine
last week and according to health
officials that shot can be administered
along with other vaccines
the summer rush to get students
vaccinated to meet
the new school year requirements is a
concern for health officials
today they urged parents to plan ahead
to avoid
any headaches before school starts in
the fall
what we will be planning to do is and
parents need to start thinking about
this
is as we're offering clothed vaccine
we'll offer all the
other school related vaccines as well
they tell us the plan is to offer the
vaccine at middle and high schools very
soon and targeting 12
to 17 year olds health officials say the
covet 19 vaccine
will not be mandatory for students but
they urge parents to protect their
children
by getting their shot